hello and welcome to math simplify
i'm dr umar malik and i hope all of you
are safe and sound
in this video we will take a look at few
remedies for a common problem that is
snoring
let's first try to understand why do
people snore
well if you snore you're not alone
according to studies up to half of all
american adults snore
when we sleep muscles and tissues in our
throat relax and become floppy so when
air flows through our throat during our
sleep vibrations are produced
this causes the harsh and irritating
snoring sounds we all know and hate too
snoring may disrupt your sleep or that
of your partner
even if it's not bothering you too much
it's not a condition you should ignore
in fact snoring may be a sign of a
serious health condition including
obstructive sleep apnea which basically
means blocked airways obesity and issue
with the structure of your mouth nose or
throat
or chronic sleep deprivation
however in other cases snoring may be
caused simply by sleeping on your back
or drinking alcohol
too close to bedtime
in some cases of snoring it's important
to seek a doctor's care in order to get
the medical treatment you need to
address the underlying condition
but there are certain simple remedies to
control snoring which we will discuss in
this video
so without further ado let's start with
our number one remedy to stop soaring
which is to lose weight
losing weight directly helps in reducing
snoring this happens because shedding
weight will not only improve your health
but it directly reduces the amount of
excess tissue in the throat
the same tissue that creates the
irritating snoring sounds
so you can begin to lose weight by
reducing your overall caloric intake
also you can switch to eating smaller
portions of food at regular intervals
and creating a diet composed of more
healthy and nutritious foods including
fruits and vegetables
also make sure that you get regular
exercise every day you may also consider
consulting your doctor or a nutritionist
for getting professional advice to
manage your diet and weight effectively
number two is to sleep on your side
when we sleep on our backs sometimes the
tongue moves to the back of the throat
this partially blocks the usual airflow
through your throat leading to snoring
sleeping on your side may be all you
need to do to allow air to flow easily
and reduce or stop your snoring
number three raise the head end of your
bed
elevating the head end of your bed by
four inches can help to reduce snoring
by keeping your airways open during
sleep time
it will also improve your oxygen levels
number four is to use nasal strips or an
external laser dilator
stick on nasal strips are easily
available in the markets today you can
either buy them online or go to a nearby
pharmacy to get them nasal strips work
on a simple concept they are placed on
the bridge of the nose and they increase
the space in the nasal passage
this can make your breathing more
effective and reduce or eliminate your
snoring
you could also try a nasal dilator which
is an adhesive tape that's applied on
the top of the nose across the nose
rails this can decrease airflow
resistance making it easier to breathe
you can try these nasal strips to help
reduce snoring
links are included in the description
down below number five
manage your chronic allergies more
effectively
allergies lead to swelling inside your
airways this can reduce airflow through
your nose which forces you to breathe
through your mouth this increases the
likelihood that you will snore talk to
your doctor about what kind of
over-the-counter prescription allergy
medications you may get to improve your
condition
number six limit or avoid alcohol before
bed
numerous studies have shown that alcohol
intake before bed can lead to increased
relaxation of throat muscles which in
turn causes snoring
so try not to consume alcohol for at
least two hours leading up to your
bedtime
this simple small habit goes a long way
to help you lead a healthy life
number seven stop smoking smoking is an
unhealthy habit studies after studies
have shown the widespread destructive
affect the smoking causes in our body
this is no exception not only you are
more likely to snore but you are more
likely to experience episodes of apnea
if you smoke so quitting smoking is the
best option for you
trying nicotine gums in patches can be
effective methods also consult your
doctor or therapist to effectively
manage your cravings
to know more about how smoking affects
your body watch our video by clicking
the banner above
number eight get enough sleep
daytime sleepiness excess tiredness and
incomplete sleep can all exacerbate your
snoring symptoms
make sure you get the recommended 7 to 8
hours of sleep you need each night your
body will respond positively to the
adequate rest and you will definitely
feel an improvement in reducing snoring
number nine
use an oral appliance
dental mall pieces called oral
appliances are also a popular method of
controlling snoring
they also work on the same principle by
keeping your air passages open
they make it easier for you to breathe
which basically prevents snoring
but you need to consult your dentist to
get one of these devices number 10
medical interventions
usually in most cases snoring resolves
with lifestyle changes and above said
methods like weight loss but in some
cases snoring causes breathing problems
to prevent that your doctor might advise
you few medical interventions these are
usually reserved as a last resort
these may include using a cpap machine
which is short for continuous positive
airway pressure if medically appropriate
wearing a pressurized air mask over your
nose when you sleep can help keep your
airway open
patients are recommended to keep the
mask on for their whole period of sleep
this treatment is often recommended to
treat patients who have breathing
difficulties associated with snoring
also known as obstructive sleep apnea
this is most commonly used medical
intervention and is effective for most
patients
palatal implants also known as pillar
procedure is a treatment that involves
injecting braided strands of polyester
filament into your mouth's soft palate
this stiffens it to reduce snoring
snoring can disrupt your sleep and that
of your partner but besides being
annoying it may indicate a serious
health condition
consulting your doctor and trying one or
more of these above treatment options
can help you get your sleep under
control
do consider leaving a like and sharing
this video
we at math simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest and updated
content every time if you would like to
support us consider subscribing and
becoming a member of our channel
on youtube or donate via patreon links
are in the description below
thank you so much and see you in the
next video